any time you're trying to come up with a
mechanism for a reaction it's worthwhile
to study a little bit of of what you are
starting with and then thinking about
what you finish with and think about
what is different so what we're starting
with we could call this one two three
four five
so this is let's see we have a methyl
group on the number two carbon it is a
pentene and that's double bond between
the number two and number three carbons
so this is two methyl
two
methyl
pent
pentuin
pentune
so that's what we start with we're in
the presence we're in a acidic
environment we've got it's going to be
catalyzed by our hydronium here and we
end up with this and how is the our
product different from what we started
with well the double bond is now gone
the number three carbon
gains this hydrogen and now the number
two carbon gains a hydroxyl group so one
way to think about this is in the
presence of an acid it's acid catalyzed
we have gained two hydrogens in an
oxygen which is well we've gained the
built that what could be used to make a
water and this is actually called an
acid catalyzed addition of water there's
the water isn't sitting on one part of
the molecule but if you take the
hydrogen we added and the hydroxyl we
added if you combine them that's that's
what you need to make a water so let's
think about how we can how this actually
happens in the presence of our hydronium
so let me redraw
this molecule right over here
so let me copy
and paste it
so
and that's not exactly it yet that is
just with the single bond
so let me draw
whoops wrong tool
let me draw
the double bond there
and now let me put it in the presence of
some hydronium
all right so we have an oxygen bonded to
so this would just be water has
oxygen has two lone pairs but hydronium
is a situation where oxygen is sharing
one of those lone pairs with a hydrogen
proton thus making the entire molecule
positive because the hydrogen you could
use the hydrogen proton was positive
so there you go this now has a positive
charge
and this can be pretty reactive because
we know that oxygen is quite
electronegative it likes to keep its
electrons so what if there was a way
what if there's a way for the oxygen to
take back the electrons in this bond
right over here the two electrons in
this bond
well what if one of these carbons
especially the ones that have the double
bonds what if some of the electrons from
this double bond could be used to snab
to take that hydrogen proton and then
oxygen can hog its electrons again
and you might say well that's that's
reasonable but which of these carbons
would actually do it and to think about
which of those carbons would do it we
have to turn to
markovnikov's rule markovnikov's rule
tells us that look if you have a
reaction like this an alkene reaction
the carbon that already has that's
already attached to more hydrogens is
more likely to gain more hydrogens the
carbon that's attached to more
functional groups is more likely to gain
more functional groups another way to
think about it is think about well what
what is the order of the carbons because
the higher order of the carbon the more
stable it will be if it forms some type
of cation so if you look at this carbon
right over here our number two carbon
let me circle it our number two carbon
is bonded to one two three carbons so
this is a tertiary carbon
this one right over here
this carbon on the other side of the
double bond is only bonded to one two
carbons so this is a secondary carbon so
the tertiary carbon is going to be more
stable as a carbocation you can think of
it as it can spread the charge a little
bit so it would be more likely to lose
the electrons in one of these in one of
these bonds and so the way that we could
think about this mechanism and it might
be a little bit clearer when it reformed
the carbocation
is let's have
i'll do this in blue
let's have these two electrons that form
this bond
well now they form a bond with that
hydrogen and now the oxygen can take
back
these two
electrons and what are we going to what
is going to result
and i'm drawing it equally remember all
these things are going back and forth
depending on how things bump into each
other but what are we left with
so let me copy and paste this again
and i'm copying and pasting it away that
i've just so i kind of this is kind of
you can view this as the backbone and
i'll add what i need to add so once this
happens
we have
this carbon the number three carbon
now
whoops i keep using the wrong tool
the number three carbon now
forms a bond with this hydrogen
just like that
this carbon our number two carbon has
lost an electron it's no longer sharing
this bond and so now it is going to have
a positive charge it is a carbocation
and once again as a tertiary carbocation
it is bounded to one two three carbons
that is stable more stable than if we
did the other way around if this one
grabbed the hydrogen somehow then this
would be a secondary carbocation it'd be
harder for it to spread that positive
charge around and what about our what
about our molecule up here let's see
what it looks like now we have our
oxygen bonded to the two hydrogens it
had one of those lone pairs and now the
electrons in this bond are now going to
form another lone pair so it took back
an electron
or you could think of it it gave away a
hydrogen proton and so this is now just
neutral water and we see that we have a
conservation of charge here this was
positively charged now our original
molecule is positively charged and what
feels good about this is we're getting
we're getting close to our end product
at least on our number three carbon we
now have
we now have this hydrogen now we need to
think about well how do we get a
hydroxyl group added right over here
well we have all this water we have all
this water floating around let me i
could use this water molecule but the
odds of it being the exact same water
molecule we don't know but there's all
sorts of water molecules we're not
aqueous solutions so let me draw another
water molecule here
so
there the water molecules are all
equivalent
but let me draw another water molecule
here
and you can imagine
it's just or if they just bump into each
other in just the right way
this is water is a is a polar molecule
has a electro it has a partially uh
negative end near the oxygen because the
oxygen likes to hog the electrons and
and then you have a partial positive end
near the hydrogens because they get
their electrons hogged so you can
imagine the oxygen and might be
attracted to this tertiary carbo cation
and so just bumping in in just the right
way it might form a bond so let me
let's say these two electrons right over
here let's say they form a bond with
this
with that number two carbon and then
what is going to result
so let me draw
so what is
what is going to result let me scroll
down a little bit
and let me
copy and paste
whoops
let me copy and paste our original
molecule again
so
there we go
so what could happen so let me construct
it actually so we have the hydrogen
there
we have the hydrogen now this character
so we have the water molecule
so oxygen bonded to two hydrogens you
have this one lone pair that isn't
reacting but then you have the lone pair
that does do the reacting
and so
it now forms a bond oops let me do it in
that orange color
it now
it now forms an actual bond and we're
really close to our final product we
have our hydrogen on the number three
carbon we have more than we want on our
number two carbon we just want a
hydroxyl group now we have a whole water
bonded to the number two carbon so
somehow we have to get one of these
other hydrogens swiped off of it well
that could happen with just another
water molecule so let's draw that
so another water molecule someplace i'll
do it in a different color just to
differentiate although as we know water
well it's hard to say even what color is
water if you're looking at the molecular
scale
so
here we go and we're really in the home
stretch at this point you have another
water molecule another water molecule
let's say
let me pick a color so let's say these
electrons right over here maybe they
form a bond with that hydrogen proton
and then
these the electrons in that bond can go
back to form a lone pair on that oxygen
and then what are we left with and this
really is the home stretch
so we are in equilibrium
with so let me draw my five carbon so
let's see i have
h3c
carbon carbon
car ac h2
ch3
i have a
ch3 i say h3c instead of ch3 i wrote it
that way just so it's clear that the
carbons are bonded to the carbons
you have
you have the original hydrogen right
over there you have the one that we just
added as a as part of this mechanism
you have this
orange bond to
now
this
hydroxyl group
the hydroxyl group and it had one lone
pair before
it had one lone pair before but now took
both of the electrons from this bond to
form another lone pair to form another
lone pair which i am depicting in pink
and then
this water is now or this water molecule
is now a hydronium molecule
so let's draw that so this is now
oxygen hydrogen hydrogen had one lone
pair that didn't react but it had one
lone pair that i put in blue that is
reacting
with this hydrogen proton
with
that hydrogen just like this and so
since it got the hydrogen proton it's
giving its electro sharing its electrons
now now this has a positive
this has a positive charge just like
that oh i have to i have to be
very careful in the last step i forgot
to draw the positive charge you always
want to make sure that your charge is
being conserved it we started off with a
positive charge on the hydronium then we
have the positive charge on a tertiary
carbocation right over here on a number
two carbon and now
we have the positive charge would be
right over here because that oxygen
what we saw before that oxygen which the
which this water molecule was neutral
but you could say you could view it as
well now it's going to be give it's now
sharing these two electrons instead of
keeping them so you could view it as
maybe it's giving it away an electron
and so now it becomes positive
and then
and then the positive charge finally
gets transferred to that other water
molecule when it becomes hydronium but
just like that we are done we have added
a hydroxyl group and a hydrogen combined
that's a water so that's why we call it
water
addition of water and it was catalyzed
by acid so it's acid acid catalyzed
addition of
water